as government employees miss paychecks
President Trump heads down to the border
democrats prep for 2020 and we checked
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
so much coming up for you here on
today's clean shaven episode of the ben
shapiro show we will get to all of it in
just one second first let's talk about
how you can save some money this is an
incredibly incredibly useful service I'm
talking of course about honey
what does honey do well here's what
honey does okay well when you go to any
normal website you may want to buy
something but then you search around
online for all the sort of promo codes
that you can use to get the discounts
honey does this for you okay honey makes
even Amazon better with millions of
sellers on Amazon selling the same
products how do you know that you're
getting the best price you don't unless
you use honey as you shop on Amazon
honey's best price finder automatically
compares the prices of millions of
sellers that carry the item that you
want honey even factors in shipping
sales tax
Amazon Prime status to make sure that
you're getting the lowest total price it
shows you the best deal every time even
if amazon doesn't it's like having your
very own smart shopping assistant now I
use Amazon all the time I have like an
Amazon Prime credit card and I use honey
even while I'm using Amazon despite the
fact I have all these great benefits
because honey makes all the products I'd
buy cheaper we had to buy gifts for my
daughter's birthday which is coming up
and I used honey saved a bunch of money
on it go check out honey right now
they've more than 10 million people
using honey honey has over a hundred
thousand five star reviews on the google
chrome store next time you're shopping
on Amazon treat yourself to a free
upgrade that guarantees you always get
the best price join honey for free at
join honey calm slash been that is join
honey calm slash men again join honey
calm slash been honey is the smart
shopping assistant helps you save time
and money check them out right now join
honey calm slash pen okay so the
government shutdown continues that pays
President Trump seriously considering
the possibility of declaring a national
emergency and then quasi activating the
military to build the wall the reason I
say quasi activating and not just
activating is because if the president
tries to activate the military to build
the wall and moves funding from certain
areas of the Defense Department toward
building that wall this will undoubtedly
be held up in court it will not get done
the only way this wall is getting done
is if the president forces the Democrats
hand if he continues to keep the
pressure on them with this government
shutdown and the longer it goes on the
worse it is not for Republicans but for
Democrats people who don't like
Republicans have already made up their
mind that Republicans are responsible
for the shutdown but people who like
Democrats are gonna have to start coming
to terms with the fact that it's their
own representatives
are telling them that they can't go back
to work because they just don't want to
spend a few billion dollars on 234 miles
of additional border fencing requested
by Border Patrol in fact if the Trump
administration really wants to avoid the
Democrats just shouting about how this
is a Trump vanity project all the Trump
administration has to do is one thing
publicly come forward and say listen we
will take a deal right now in which 5.7
billion dollars is allocated directly to
Border Patrol to do with as they see fit
they will make recommendations to
Congress and to the executive branch and
then we will just go ahead and take
those recommendations and they can use
the money so it's not even about what
Trump's personal priorities are he just
wants to do what Border Patrol needs and
Border Patrol needs a wall today The
Associated Press reports that President
Trump is edging closer to declaring a
national emergency to fund that
long-promised border wall as pressure
mounts to find an escape hatch from the
three-week impasse that has closed parts
of the government leaving the hundreds
of thousands of workers without pay some
800,000 workers more than half of them
still on the job or to miss their first
paycheck today under the stoppage
Washington was close to setting a
dubious record for the longest
government shutdown in the nation's
history now again it's a partial
government shutdown it is not a total
government shutdown all the essential
services are still running if you go to
the airport today TSA will still be
there annoying you and giving you rectal
exams if you go to to to get your
welfare check today you're still gonna
be able to pick up and welfare check
today food stamps are still operating
right Social Security is still sending
out checks all these things are still
happening it's non-essential government
employees who have been furloughed and
then everybody else is still working and
if their paycheck gets delayed by a week
or two which is what's likely to happen
then they will get their back pay and
that's always what happens everybody
gets their back pay it's not as though
people are working for free nobody at
the government works for free asked
about it the play to those working
without pay the president shifted the
focus saying he felt bad for people that
have family members that have been
killed by criminals who came over the
border which seems to me a perfectly
rational response the Democrats want to
talk about all the people who are not
getting paid for five days while the
government is shut down Trump I think
his right to focus on okay well you know
what they could get paid and also we
could have less dead people in the
United States and when folks on the Left
say well immigrants to this country
provide less crime than homegrown
Americans that's mostly true of legal
immigrants not necessarily the illegal
immigrants kind of hard to measure
because most states don't actually
tract of illegal immigrant crime
seriously it's an amazing thing if you
ask how many murders have been committed
in the state of California by illegal
immigrants there's no actual hard
statistic on this because the state of
California refuses to keep such
statistics with that said should there
be even one crime committed by an
illegal immigrant the answer of course
is no and certainly not many crimes and
many crimes are committed by illegal
immigrants Trump visited McAllen Texas
and the Rio Grande on Thursday to
highlight what he calls a crisis of
Drugs and Crime here's President Trump
at the border talking about how we
absolutely need a wall there's gonna be
some death if we don't have a wall this
is common sense they need a barrier they
need a wall if you don't have it it's
going to be nothing but a hard work and
grueling problems and by the way and
death and death a lot of death I want to
thank you you do a fantastic job
president I appreciate that thank you
very much you can see senator Cruz down
there at the world later today on our
radio show we're having on senator Cruz
to talk about president Trump's borah
visit the presumably president Trump
would earmark money for the Army Corps
of Engineers looking for billions of
dollars in other places so one of the
places would be taking money away from
disaster response in Puerto Rico again
this is the reason why the president
shouldn't do this is because if he takes
money away from the from these disaster
response in Puerto Rico the claims will
be that his shortchanged Puerto Rico in
order to build the wall when in reality
all that has to happen here is President
Trump needs to keep on the pressure he
did a decent job of that yesterday right
going down to the border and pushing
more is a good idea he sat next to the
brother of a man who was slain by
illegal immigrants and this guy I think
gave a pretty convincing case as to
exactly why it is that a border wall is
necessary the way he was killed
what my family is going through right
now I do not want any other family law
enforcement person to go through that
whatever it takes to minimize put a stop
to it
my family fully supports it at 33 years
old
Ronelle Singh was cremated and I had to
pick up his remains it breaks my heart
and no one should ever ever go through
that media coverage of this stuff by the
way is utterly extraordinary terrible
the AAP for example talks about how
president from visited McAllen Texas and
he view tables piled with weapons and
narcotics like nearly all drugs
trafficked across the border they were
intercepted by agents and official ports
of entry he was told and not in the
remote areas where he wants to extend
tall barriers still he declared a wall
works
nothing like a wall well did it ever
occur to people that people are
smuggling through ports of entry because
it is most convenient the reason they're
not walking across the the unguarded
areas of the border is because they're
very far away meaning that if you extend
the wall you are forcing more people
into the port of entry think of flow of
human beings the same way you think of
flow of water if you redirect the flow
of water toward one specific point then
at least you have a choke point if you
leave the flow of water to go wherever
it wants on the table it's gonna go
wherever it wants on the table
okay so just because most of the water
is already moving through a choke point
doesn't mean all the water is moving
through the choke point the question is
how you get more people to move through
those ports of entry and also upgrade
the technology at those ports of entry
the media keep claiming this is a
manufactured crisis it's not a
manufactured crisis nothing's been
manufactured here this is a this is a
long-standing government failure the
federal government has been a giant fail
on all of this for a very very long time
for decades and President Trump is at
least attempting to do something about
it for that he deserves credit he only
gets full credit if something actually
gets done about it again the media
coverage of this is asinine Jim Acosta
at CNN is just he's hilariously bad at
his job I mean it's as though we in the
in the conservative movement constructed
a reporter specifically designed to make
CNN look bad it's as though he went into
a lab and we decided to take a few
sprinkles of stupid and add it to a
large dash of arrogance and then just
toss it in a weird-looking reporter
package and put it out there
CNN that's what Jim Acosta is so he goes
down to the border in Texas and he
stands next to a steel slatted wall
exactly what Trump wants to build and
then for some reason he thinks he's
owning the cons when he says that
there's no crisis at this part of the
border you think maybe it's the wall
you're standing next to you dope here's
Jim Acosta really what my favorite part
of this he's getting to the video Jim
Acosta stands at the border wall and
there's a smug grin of satisfaction that
washes over his face at the end of this
clip as though he has just come up with
a brilliant point nobody has ever come
up with before the Pulitzer is on its
way here is Jim Acosta at CNN and here
are some of the steel slats that the
president's been talking about right
here as you can see yes you can't see
through these slats to the other side of
the us-mexico border but as we're
walking along here we're not seeing any
kind of imminent danger there are no
migrants trying to rush toward this
fence here in the McAllen Texas area as
a matter of fact there are some other
businesses behind me along this highway
there's a gas station Burger King and so
on but no sign of the national emergency
that the president has been talking
about as a matter of fact it's pretty
tranquil down here Wow you mean it's
really tremble next to the wall you mean
next to the steel slats Trump wants to
build it's really tranquil over there
he's a stupid so president Trump it's a
president Trump drops one of the best
tweets of his presidency last night
there's this meme that's been going
around for a long time
it was started you know a year ago by by
a guy named Harry catch at Harry but it
was really popularized by a twitter user
named neon taster who started tweeting
out before every Jim Acosta tweet dear
diary because everything that Jim Acosta
does is specifically kind of his little
mash note to himself and so President
Trump picked up on that and last night
he took Jim Acosta sweet and he just
tweeted dear diary yes that is some
high-level trolling you have to love
that stuff that is well done mr.
president I mean this is why we elected
him right not to build the wall we elect
him for tweets like this that's what we
care about let's let's be real about
this pretty pretty delicious stuff from
the President of the United States as an
added benefit Jim Acosta hates the dear
diary meme so much that a few weeks ago
somebody tweeted at him the dear diary
meme and
back at them FeO that's solid step by
the way speaking of media malfeasance is
a pretty amazing story CNN is denying of
course this is the case but there is a
local news outlet Kusi in San Diego and
CNN had been calling around to local
news outlets and asking them if there
was a reporter who'd want to come on CNN
and talk about the border issue only one
problem their reporters over at Kusi
believe that border wall is necessary
because they've been reporting on the
actual border unlike CNN which has most
of its reporters stationed in major
cities Kusi actually has reporters on
the border pretty regularly CNN calls
them up never give them a call back
because it turns out Kos I doesn't agree
with them we'll talk about that in just
one second first let's talk about how
you can protect yourself from tyranny
how you can protect yourself in your own
home when the founders crafted the
Constitution they wanted to make sure
you can protect your rights and that's
why they gave you the Second Amendment
that's why they made sure that your
natural right to self-defense was
enshrined in the Constitution of the
United States
the folks at Bravo Company manufacturing
agree with the founders it was started
in a garage by a Marine veteran more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or whether
they are professional BCM is not a
sporting arms company you've heard me
talk about the Second Amendment I always
say the Second Amendment is important
not really because I like hunting
because I don't actually hunt it's
important to me the reason I own guns is
for self-defense and protection against
tyranny BCM believes the same thing each
components of a BCM rifle has hands
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard they design
engineer manufacturer life-saving
equipment they assume every rifle
leaving their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or
soldier overseas to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to bravo company MFG comm again his
bravo company MFG comm you can discover
more about their product special offers
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm if you need more convincing finds
out even more about BCM and the awesome
people who make their products over at
youtube.com slash bravo company USA i
know the founders of the company
fantastic folks go check them out
bravo company MFG calm or youtube.com
slash bravo company USA alright so this
local news station Kusi reported
yesterday on CNN basically ignoring them
as soon as Kusi made clear that they
actually believe president Trump is
correct about the border wall
CNN asked if Kusi would provide a
reporter to offer our local view of the
debate especially to learn if the wall
works in San Diego Kusi offered our own
dan Plante who's reported many times
that the wall is not an issue here in
fact most officials believe it is
effective now knowing this CNN declined
to have us on their programs which often
present the wall as not required in
other places like the stretch of the
Texas border the president visited
earlier today they didn't like what they
heard from us well of heard our seat for
CNN's partner Oliver Darcy responded by
saying we've had on Kusi reporters
before we asked note a lot of people but
some of those people don't don't want to
don't end up being brought onto the
programs okay I have my doubts that a
lot of reporters are gonna be brought on
to actually specifically back president
Trump's basic points here because
obviously CNN doesn't support the
president's basic point Democrats
meanwhile are struggling for a response
to President Trump you know the media
portrayed this as though the Democrats
are just fine and dandy everything is
cool the fact is as the government
shutdown extends their own constituents
are gonna look at them and say why are
you not just giving the president what
he wants this doesn't seem wildly
unreasonable especially in light of
stories like this one this one from CNN
on inconvenient for CNN Mexican
authorities found at least 20 bodies
most of them burned along the dirt road
in the northern state of Tamaulipas
Durand near the US border officials said
the bodies were found Wednesday
afternoon near Fort charred pickup
trucks in a sedan in the rural community
of Refugio Hinojosa near the town of
Miguel Elmen federal police said I know
my accent is awful several photos
provided by police showed some remains
next to the burned-out wreckage of the
vehicles turns out that Mexico is kind
of a violent place
lots of people getting killed over in
Mexico and maybe we ought to you know
extend our protection of the borders
that doesn't cross the border it's
amazing to me how many Democrats will go
to the safer areas and not and
completely neglects the non safe areas
my business partner actually has a movie
called the Arroyo about the non safe
areas of the us-mexico border and if you
go and you talk to ranchers specifically
along that border ranchers and area is
not protected by fencing not protected
by wall they will tell you that their
land is used for trespass by drug
traffickers for human smuggling they
will tell you that the levels of
violence they
seen in their immediate area is actually
really high there's their vast swathes
of wilderness land they're basically
been taken over by the cartels I mean
all of this has been known for a really
long time the media just don't want to
report on it right now because it would
cut in president Trump's favor well
meanwhile the Republicans are trying to
figure out exactly what to do because
the Democrats have been obviously not
very forthcoming Democrats don't have a
good moral response they just keep
yelling about Trump it's amazing here
Ono who was just an awful awful
senator she's the senator from Hawaii
she's most famous recently for shouting
about Brett Kavanaugh being a gang
rapist or something mazie Hirono she
came and said we don't negotiate with
immoral hostage-takers you know it's
really funny
whenever President Trump says something
nasty about Democrats and people like me
say you know he really shouldn't say
something nasty about Democrats like
yesterday President Trump said that it
was easier to negotiate with the Chinese
Communists you know actual human rights
violators then Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer and I said you shouldn't say
that then the Democrats just say
whatever they want and nobody seems to
bat an eye
there's mazie Hirono calling the
president an immoral hostage taker for
suggesting that we need more protection
along the southern border tomorrow
because he makes no difference between
right or wrong nor does it give a rip
and he's a hostage taker because he has
taken 800,000 federal employees and
thousands and thousands of contractors
hostage and we don't negotiate with a
moral hostage taker so basically she is
calling the president's a terrorist so
the president says that he wants to
ensure that the border is safe and she
calls him a terrorist and where where's
the media saying that her rhetoric is
overheated it's amazing which rhetoric
is overheated Republican rhetoric has
always overheated no matter what but
Democrats literally called Tea Partiers
terrorists for years on end and the
media basically went along with all of
that it's it's pretty astonishing the
Republicans are meanwhile trying to
figure out what to do so of course the
president has mentioned the possibility
of a national emergency I've been
explaining consistently over the past
couple of days why I think that would be
a bad idea that would not actually
achieve the president's goals why in
fact it would just result in maybe a
political win kind of for the president
but not in an actual win in terms of a
more secure border like Ann Coulter is
not going to sign off on it nor should
she for example so here is
he grabbed me tweeted out yesterday that
he wanted President Trump to declare
national emergency' then he said the
same I have never been more depressed
about moving forward them right now I
just don't see a pathway forward
somebody's gonna like give some energy
to fix this I'm a pretty hawkish guy on
powers of the commander-in-chief he
tried to do this under the inherent
authority of the commander-in-chief
under Article two I'm saying you know
I'm the commander in chief this is a
national security event I'm gonna
redirect funding for traditional
military functions to border security I
would have a problem of that so the
bottom line is that you know when
Lindsey Graham says this I think it's
because Lindsey Graham has a close
connection with the president he said
speaker Pelosi's refusal to negotiate on
funding for a border wall or barrier
even if the government were to be
reopened virtually ends the
Congressional path to funding a border
wall barrier it is time for President
Trump to use emergency powers to fund
the construction of a border wall and
barrier I hope it works I hope it works
is not a good sign
I mean kitten-like if your doctor if you
go in your doctor you're not just like I
think that you need a surgery I think
you may have cancer you need a surgery I
hope it works buy life insurance now
right that I hope it works is not
something you want to hear your
legislators saying particularly
particularly on your own site it won't
work and you Lindsey Graham knows it
won't work the president is going to use
the national emergency thing as sort of
a last-ditch pull on the parachute and
in case of emergency pulled that
parachute and hopefully glide to a
political victory but it's not actually
going to work what is going to work if
anything is going to work is the
president continuing to force Democrats
to defend their own positions now what's
what's awkward about this is that for
the Democrats they don't actually have a
solid case against the bearer of the war
on the wall they don't have a solid case
against the border wall barrier they
really don't I have yet to hear a well
articulated case against the border wall
barrier or against in additional federal
sponging and spending on on the border
wall or giving more money to Border
Patrol the Democrats have not made that
case and that's because the only thing
that really unites Democrats the only
thing that really unites Democrats is
their hatred for president Trump just as
Republicans during the Obama era really
only united by their hatred for
President Obama's agenda the Democrats
are really only united by their hatred
for president Trump personally not even
his agenda president from on a very
personal level how much do the
Kratts hate President Trump this much so
Harry Reid you remember that sleaze bet
a sleaze bucket Harry Reid former Senate
Majority and Minority Leader yeah then
he of the Nevada whorehouse where he
grew up Harry Reid claimed that MIT
Romney had not paid his taxes if you
recall back in 2012 he suggested that
MIT Romney had dodged his taxes and he
said he had special information
suggesting that and then it turns out he
lied and then when asked about it Harry
Reid said well it worked didn't it
because MIT Romney didn't win now
Harry Reid said that he and MIT Romney
had differences in the past but he
thinks that Romney's great now and he
thinks that he's a moderate voice the
Republicans need Harry Reid insisted he
had claimed Romney hadn't paid his fair
share of taxes rather than owed taxes
and said he was glad he'd raised the
issue at the time but now he says I
think he would be a great foil against
Trump I think Republicans may even allow
him to be nominated to be the Republican
nominee that would be good for the
country it's just it's astonishing that
this is how much the Democrats hate
Trump they hate Trump so much that MIT
Romney is now wonderful by the way this
is not unusual right if four years after
Donald Trump is gone Democrats will look
back and say you remember when there was
that Donald Trump guy and he's so modern
remember that Donald Trump with low
moderate on spending remember Donald
Trump used to talk about spending
trillions of dollars on infrastructure
and national health care because every
every Republican eventually for
Democrats is is sort of caused over in
the Vaseline of time every every
Republican eventually becomes kind of
soft focused and you remember when
George W Bush used to work with
Democrats it was a better time a nicer
it wasn't a better time it wasn't a
nicer times iMac rats were just as awful
as they are now I was there I remember
same thing with Mitt Romney but this is
how much they hate President Trump is
now they are relegated to whining about
the the glories of Mitt Romney as the
only thing that really ties together the
Democratic Party at this point which is
why in 2020 the Democratic Party is
going to come apart again because
they're really too many constituent
groups inside the Democratic Party this
is the best hope for president Trump's
at re-election as for the Democratic
Party to start coming apart at the seams
again right now they are competing for
the most left-leaning point they can
make according to the Washington Times a
bunch of Democrats are basically now
competing to set the top tax bracket of
course Alexandra Ocasio cortes he's not
running for president but would if she
were 35 wanted to set
tax bracket at 70% who Ian Castro an
Obama administration cabinet official
who also wants to run for president he
says that he wants it to be around 90%
Elizabeth Warren says that she wants it
to be well above 50% so the Democrats
keep just kind of ratcheting this thing
up now they're never going to implement
any of this policy of course none of
them are interested in implementing the
policy but they have to compete for the
most left-leaning person who can rip on
Donald Trump that's a 20/20 is all about
we're gonna get into the Democratic
candidates for president in just a
minute because they just made fools of
themselves yesterday first let's talk
about how you can make your business
more efficient the small steps lead to
big changes it's important to think
about that entering a new year it's
important to remember that LegalZoom can
help you take those steps now I have a
new year's resolution to cut down on my
social media usage so far fail but the
only way that I can actually succeed in
this task is if I take small steps like
when I get home taking my phone and
putting it on the bedside stand and
leaving it there for you know 10 minutes
at a time with their network of
independent attorneys licensed in all 50
states LegalZoom can help you take the
small steps you need to make your
business much more efficient from wills
and trusts to LLC's trademarks
contractor of using more LegalZoom has
helped more than 4 million people like
you take care of their responsibilities
the best part is that Legal Zoom is not
a law firm so you won't get charged by
the hour
I love legals from I've been using Legal
Zoom for years on forms like wills and
trusts and and contracts but now they
actually have an independent team of
attorneys will look over your legal work
make this the year you finally do the
right thing for your business visit
legalzoom.com right now for special
savings be sure to enter promo code
Shapiro in the referral box to check out
that is promo code Shapiro for special
savings only at legalzoom.com that is
legalzoom.com where life meets legal go
check them out right now legalzoom.com
promo code Shapiro for special savings
so the Democratic Party primary for 2020
is now fuller than a clown car at the
circus every person and their brother I
don't want to miss gender anybody every
person and their and their sibling of
self decided sex is running for
president in the Democratic Party Kamala
Harris is already declaring that she's
gonna run of course she's gonna run the
only reason she ran for Senator in
California is to run it's the only
reason anyone runs for Senator in
California anymore
here's Kamala Harris an awful Attorney
General in the state of California and
even more awful senator from California
saying she wants to run for president
because as I've been saying for a while
she knows that she has a certain
percentage of the Democratic base
more likely to vote for her I'm speaking
of course of the racially polarized
nature of democratic party primaries
that's what led to Barack Obama being
the nominee in 2008 Kamala Harris wants
to bet on running exactly that same
gamut that's it that same gauntlet here
she is with Stephen Colbert I will say
the guest's election on Colbert is just
astonishing the propaganda effect of
having late-night television hosts
dedicate all of their time to democratic
guests it's it's so uncited it's well
the last time you saw a Republican
senator on one of these late-night shows
to be treated with respect not mocked
like to actually just be treated with
respect
the answer is never it Stephen Colbert
has the pod save America Bros on fairly
regularly from what I understand you
know it'll be a it will be a cold day in
hell before Stephen Colbert ever would
invite somebody from the right like
yours truly on his program I imagine the
same is true of people like Jimmy Kimmel
anyway here's Stephen Colbert with
Kamala Harris who smiles and nods as
Jimmy K as Stephen Colbert asks her if
she's gonna run for president
[Applause]
she might append she's nodding and
smiling hoes and everybody knows she's
gonna run for president everybody has
known she was gonna run for president it
does show you the nature of our racially
polarized politics that anyone thinks
that Kamala Harris is a serious
candidate
she has no record in the Senate she's
been in the Senate for five minutes
the only reason anyone is taking her
seriously is because she is a black
woman
that's the only reason okay because Amy
Klobuchar has a significantly better
record as a senator from Minnesota she's
a much better senator she's much more
likable she's much more coherent
nobody's talking Amy Klobuchar and
Kirsten Gillibrand has the same record
as Kamala Harris
nobody likes Kirsten Gillibrand it shows
you the I mean it's even at five thirty
eight so five thirty gate has a
breakdown today of what they call the
five groups inside the Democratic party
primaries and it's groups like
Millennials and the left and then the
party and then they have two other
groups blacks and Hispanics / Asians
okay well when you're breaking down your
party primaries into ethnic groups that
might suggest there's a problem with
your ideology you know we on the right
have accepted that and believe I really
believe this conservatives really
believe that race should not be a factor
in deciding whether something is good or
true and if you believe that race should
be a factor in deciding whether
something is good or true you're a
racist right I mean this is why we
discussed Steve King on the show
yesterday and get some more Steve King
in a little while here but the the
Democratic Party has no problem
accepting the inherent racism of their
own of their own party breakdown it
meanwhile that the guy who's supposed to
be leading among the Millennial crew is
beta or orc Vader or Erick apparently
believes that everything you do in life
must be live-streamed so he actually
live-streamed his trip to the dentist I
kid you not on Instagram he
live-streamed his teeth cleaning and
he's talked to the dental technician
about illegal immigration policy I know
that's what I do I know that when I go
for a teeth cleaning the first thing
that I do is I ask my dental technician
about the budget I ask him at the
federal budget and prioritization of
defense spending versus education spent
here is beta or work doing pretty much
exactly that at the dentist office
yesterday
so I'm here at the dentist and we're
going to continue our series on the
people of the border I'm here with Diana
hi I'm Diana I was actually am born here
in El Paso my mom is from a small town
in Mexico what is my goal my dad was a
u.s. resident US citizen I'm sorry do
you want people to know about the border
that it's a beautiful community we all
support each other we love each other
and it's not what everybody else thinks
badly about us it's it's actually a
wonderful place to live in grow up any
one thing form to walk in and just do
like a little interview yeah she lives
from apartment clean his teeth so
yesterday by coincidence
like six months ago I'd scheduled a
dental appointment so I did take a
little video of myself having my teeth
cleaned and then I told bata or work
that plaque doesn't care about your
feelings in any case beta O'Rourke
you know demonstrating that all that
seems to matter inside the Democratic
Party at this point is sort of
clickability
that's that's actually exasperated
emma-crats inside the party this is
particularly true with regard to
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez long article in
Politico today about how a OC is already
making enemies in the house Democratic
caucus because all she does on Twitter
is self glorify and rip other Democrats
and so Democrats are saying like what's
the deal ladies you actually want to be
part of a governing coalition or do you
just want to be popular the answer she
just wants to be popular because this is
the path to political power now it's not
governing it's not forming coalition's
instead it's just tweeting things
apparently the Democrats recruited a
woman named Nydia Velazquez from New
York and she's representative she also
what knocked off a longtime Democratic
incumbent to win her seat she also has
Puerto Rican roots and she's been trying
to convince how kasnia Cortez to stop
ripping on Democrats for the past few
months and this has been somewhat
unavailing other lawmakers are ticked at
her you vet Clarke is a fellow New York
Democrat says I think she needs to give
herself an opportunity to know her
colleagues and to give herself a sense
of the chemistry of the body before
passing judgment on anyone or anything
represented Kurt Schrader of Oregon said
she's new here feeling the way around
she doesn't understand how the place
works yet but that doesn't matter she's
now the most popular Congress person in
America among Democrats may be outside
of Nancy Pelosi maybe not outside of
Nancy Pelosi shows you why the social
media millennial generation is live
streaming teeth cleanings for the 2020
race meanwhile Bernie Sanders is taking
on the chin from the intersectional
nature of his own party so there are
members of his campaign staff apparently
who sexually harassed women and now
Bernie Sanders is being forced to answer
for it he says to the women on my 2016
campaign who harassed or mistreated
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for speaking out I apologize
we can't just us talk about ending
sexism and discrimination it must be a
reality in our daily lives this was
clearly not the case in 2016
okay so Bernie Sanders is being
railroaded by a bunch of the folks on
the far left who would prefer that you
vote for Elizabeth Warren or bata
O'Rourke in the Millennial / far-left
category of the of the can burn Ebro
2020 Democratic primary in just a second
I want to get to the the Steve King
issue because I have some more words
about I've discussed it a little bit
yesterday I want to talk a little bit
more about it today first I need to talk
to you about how you can make your
business better do you look around the
office do you think I gotta go but bunch
of slobs working here I mean just come
on well that's why you need legal it
that's why you need separate quarters if
recruiters gonna make sure that you are
able to get the best folks for your
office even if you got a bunch of great
people working for you just want to
expand your business you need zip
recruiter start the year off strong by
going to zip recruiting calm / daily
wire to hire the right people
unlike other job sides if worker finds
qualified candidates just for you they
have powerful matric technology I scan
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invite them
to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast that is why
zipper crew is rated number one by
employers in the United States that
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at zip recruit comm slash at
daily wire we use zip recruiter right
here at the daily wire if you love this
show show your support to it and zip
recruiter go to zip recruit comm slash
daily wire again that zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired you can try it out for
free zip recruiter exact comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ok so I do want to
talk about Steve King a little bit more
because I have some notes
not just on Steve King but on the
Democratic response on folks on the left
their response to to Steve King and his
racist remarks from yesterday I also
want to get into the mailbag if you're a
subscriber you could ask me questions in
the mailbag which is why you should
subscribe right now you can
asking me live questions you could be
preparing to have your life better for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show life you get two more hours later
today we are slaving away for you folks
we're bringing the best in content the
show's basically now an all-day show ask
my employees ask the ask Sonya who's
getting up at 4:00 in the morning and
working herself to death just for you
all you have to do is subscribe just go
there and subscribe right now $9.99 a
month and 499 dollars a year you get all
that great stuff and you also get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr look
at this thing look at it you could be
experiencing the joy that is this tumblr
if all you did was just spend $9.99 a
month but less than that 99 bucks a year
just go get the annual right now also as
a reminder I am speaking at the March
for Life Friday January 18th at the
National Mall in Washington DC it's an
amazing event I'm honored to be a part
of it I'd love to see you out there
supporting the most worthy cause in
America advocating for the rights of our
unborn children I definitely hope to see
you there Tim be a blast for me
live-streaming the podcast from there
and then I'm gonna be speaking at the
actual March so it should be a blast I'm
really hoping to see you there also make
sure that you subscribe over at YouTube
and iTunes we have all sorts of goodies
coming for you great Sunday specials
coming up so much good stuff coming all
the time go check that out we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in America
[Music]
so while the Democrats slug it out over
who's going to take the mantle and it's
really about who takes the anti-trump
mantle there's one basic truth inside
the Democratic Party and that is no one
is too radical for the Democratic Party
the reason I bring this up is because
yesterday Steve King got himself in how
are the representative from Iowa got
himself in desert hot water for
suggesting that white supremacism and
white nationalism or not in fact bad
terms which is disgusting white
nationalism is racist white supremacism
is racist they belong in glorious evil
history in the United States and
elsewhere and folks like me came out and
slammed Steve King I maxed out for on
the federal level in giving to his
primary opponents in Iowa I urged others
to do the same he identified Western
civilization with white supremacy which
is insane it's an argument made by the
left the left likes to claim that
Western civilization is in fact a an
aftereffect of white supremacism that
basically Western civilization was built
for white folks and that anyone who's
not white can't be a part of Western
civilization which is why I should tear
it down Steve King seems to be making a
similar argument except saying Western
civilization should be upheld by barring
people who are not of the proper race
that's disgusting
it's evil and it's wrong House
Republicans came out and immediately
slammed King so House Republicans Liz
Cheney who's the head of one of the
caucuses inside the House Republican
caucus she says these comments are
important and racist they should have no
place in our national discourse and then
she's not the only one condemning him
Kevin McCarthy who's the House Minority
Leader he came out and slammed Steve
King as well he said that his comments
were basically reckless and disgusting
he said that the comments have no place
in our society he said everything about
white supremacy and white nationalism
goes against who we are as a nation
Steve's language is reckless wrong has
no place in our society the Declaration
of Independence states that all men are
created equal that is a fact it is
self-evident now I have a few comments
that I need to make about the response
by folks on the left to the right
condemning King so virtually everybody
on the right as a unit came out and
condemned Steve King and the left had
two responses one what took you so long
where were you when Steve came was
saying stuff that was borderline for
years and two Steve King believes all
the same things you believe so those are
really bad things so let's take that
second claim first so the second claim
is one made by Chris Hayes so Chris
Hayes tweets out it is entirely a
coincidence
that the congressman
here building a model of border wall on
the House floor in 2006 is today saying
he doesn't understand why white
supremacists should have negative
connotations and then he tweeted out a
video of Steve King from 2006 actually
physically building a model border wall
on the House floor okay so here's the
deal a lot of people who agree with you
on specific policies may in fact have
malign motives or be bad people this is
true no matter which side of the aisle
you stands on just because somebody
agrees with me about tax rates does not
mean they are a good person in other
parts of their lives or that they are
not agreeing with me about tax rates for
the right reasons maybe they're agreeing
for the wrong reasons but the left's
immediate jump to Steve King is in favor
of white supremacism and he's also in
favor of a border wall therefore if you
are in favor of a border wall it's
because you're a borderline white
supremacist is disgusting it is a smear
by association and it is logically
untenable the left knows this but
they're not gonna stop doing it this is
the routine that they do every single
every single time with folks on the
right they say oh well you know you're
on the right you believe X you know who
else believes X Hitler it's like well
yeah Hitler had a dog you know Hitler
presumably won in more government
spending Saudi Democrats Hitler
centralized the economy in Germany so
two Democrats a doesn't mean they're
Hitler and it doesn't mean they're doing
it for the same reason that kind of
logical trick is really repellent it's
quite repellent so that is point number
one Democrats are making that's really
dumb point number two is the idea why
didn't you catch on to Steve Kings
routine earlier and the reason for most
Republicans and I think it is fair to
say this for most of the people in the
Republican caucus is most people thought
that Steve King was just an idiot and so
they gave him the benefit of the doubt
they thought that Steve King was just a
dummy that he says dumb things a lot and
that when he is trying to articulate
defences of Western civilization he does
so in the dumbest possible way he may
not know that he's not a racist if
there's a way to read his comments and
two ways to read his comments one that
is kind of giving him the benefit of the
doubt inland that's not well give him
the benefit of the doubt well yesterday
he said something where he can't give
him the benefit of the doubt and it
exposes maybe the malign motives behind
everything else that he's been saying
for years right I mean that is the case
now folks on the left jump down the
throats of people on the right why why
would they do that after the right says
okay you know what you guys were right
Steve Kings a bad guy right why why
after that did the left decide to jump
down the throats of people on the right
because the left believes
that every individual instance of racism
is a proof that all the things are
racist the left are a bunch of people
who have a religious worldview about
things like racism every ill in American
life can be chalked up to white
privilege and the evils of Western
civilization and white supremacy and
racism and so when there's an actual
case of white supremacy and racism it
becomes indicative of the entire
civilization the entire culture the
entire Republican Party you see this
every time there is an actual racist
police shooting if there's an actual
racist police shooting the left
immediate immediately declares that
police across the nation are the problem
police across the Nate this is just
indicative this anecdotal case is
indicative of a broad widespread public
perspective about racism and the nice
thing for the left is that this is
unfalsifiable because here's how it
works
the left says in instance is racism I
say well you know what I'm really not
sure that that's racism
in fact I think that you're interpreting
that wrong then two years later there's
another incident when I say you know
what that's a racist incident of to see
see that's a racist incident that means
you were wrong about that first incident
that means you've been wrong all along
now in reality if you try to say that
some things are racist and some things
are not and you try to actually divine
which things are racist and which are
not you are more likely to be correct
than the person who religiously says
that things are racist anybody who says
that everything is racist is is making a
an evidence list religious argument but
if you religiously believe it then that
means that every piece of evidence in
your favor becomes yet another brick in
your wall of belief and all of the
counts are evidence you just ignore and
that's what's been happening as I said
yesterday on the radio show as I said
yesterday there I got notes from people
basically saying oh look at Republicans
Republicans they never clean house and
Steve King is just an example of the
fact that Republicans are constantly
having to clean house because their
party is rife with bad people and my
response is no that's evidence that we
do clean house you folks on the left
never clean house and to the left says
you guys are had to throw out Roy Moore
you've had to throw out Steve King
you've had to throw out all sorts of bad
Joe Arpaio you've had to throw out all
sorts of bad people that shows that your
party has a lot of bad people
whereas we we've never thrown out
anybody bad that means that no one bad
is in our caucus well my answer to that
is no there are tons of bad people in
your caucus it's just that you're too
lazy stupid or wrong
throw those people out in a second I'm
going to show you the proof of this
because it turns out that the left has
never thrown anyone out for radicalism
ever the left embraces their radicals
the left has they don't clean house at
all so the right cleans house on a
regular basis which means sometimes the
house is dirty the left has never
cleaned house to them this is evidence
that the house was always clean to
anyone rational it's evidence that the
house is full to the brim with garbage
that basically the Democrats been
hoarding their garbage for years and
never cleaning house okay so here's the
evidence at the same time that
Republicans are coming out on mass and
condemning Steve King el Sharpton is
being welcomed into the Hall of Congress
by alexandre al khazneh cortez the
hottest young thing in the Democratic
Party I don't mean that you know in a in
a female term I mean she's the hot new
thing on the block for Democrats so
Alexander Ocasio Cortez who Hobnobs with
actual anti-semites like Linda Sarsour
she brings el Sharpton a man who not
once but twice was involved in nearly
inciting riots or inciting riots in New
York against Jews that guy is welcome to
dance with Alexandra Ocasio Cortez in
the halls of Congress on the same day
that Steve King is being condemned
roundly and rightly by the Republican
Party
so here's Ocasio Cortez dancing with a
guy who once said about Jews that they
should pin back their yarmulkes and come
fight him and who suggested that their
white interlopers at Harlem here she is
dancing with him promised her
[Laughter]
okay and then this is the Democrats
never toss anybody out never for
radicalism the only times Democrats get
tossed is when they become inconvenient
like Al Franken because he was grabbing
every ass he could find it's
legitimately the only time the Democrats
ever get tossed otherwise they're
they're welcome to stay another example
Angela Davis right she was the women's
March honoree so at Gonzaga University I
have been banned right I'm not allowed
to speak at cansada University because I
don't meet their Jesuit values you know
who was allowed to speak against Agra
University Angela Davis
you know he's welcomed by the women's
March Angela Davis Democrats like Angela
Davis they find her inspiring who is
Angela Davis well if you don't remember
Angela Davis because you're not old
enough Angela Davis is an actual
honest-to-god Stalinist David Harris ani
has a good piece over at the Federalist
today talking about this says just as
Davis wasn't merely a communist
sympathizer but a champion of the most
reprehensible Soviet regimes she's not
merely a supporter of boycott divestment
and sanctions Jewish boycotts but a
champion of men like Marwan Barghouti
the al-aqsa Martyrs Brigade leader who
coordinated suicide bombings targeting
Jewish civilians
yet somehow Davis claimed to be stunned
when she was rejected from the
Birmingham Civil Rights Institute they
were going to give her an award and then
they rescinded it
but Sally cone Wright who's a welcome
contributor on CNN she says that she
still stands with Davis because of her
fight against the prison industrial
complex NPR described Angela Davis as a
human rights activist she bought the
shotgun Angela Davis that was used in a
1970 Marin County courtroom kidnapping
and shootout that ended up killing a
Superior Court judge and three others
she fled to Cuba in 1971 the CIA noted
that Davis's case had become a Soviet
manipulated international anti us
campaign reminiscent on the orchestrated
by communist propaganda efforts made on
behalf of atomic spies Ethel and Julius
Rosenberg the CIA estimated that at
least five percent of the entire Soviet
Russia propaganda budget had been aimed
at propping up Angela Davis personally
now she's a woke leader among folks on
the left and Ilhan Omar and Rashid it's
alive are not only welcome in the
Democratic caucus they are celebrated
Rashidah Talib has come out in the last
couple of weeks and said openly
anti-semitic things she said that
basically they're a bunch of Congress
members with dual loyalties to Israel
she is not only well she
champion she's championed Democrats can
complain tulsi gabbard wrote a piece
yesterday we talked about it complaining
about
mazie Hirono going after catholics has
mazie Hirono really felt the brunt from
the her democratic party brethren of
course not
has Bernie Sanders who did the same
thing with regard to Catholicism felt
the brunt from his Democratic Party
colleagues no of course not he's
considered a frontrunner for president
so before you lecture people on the
right who are actively trying to clean
house about their inability to clean
house you might want to look at the fact
that Democrats have never once clean
house not once
it's disgusting and if Democrats to sit
on their high horse and then criticize
when you do try to clean house is just
an indicator that in their religious
worldview leftism can never be too
radical but mainstream conservatism is
just part and parcel of white
supremacism which is an absolute
untoward lie okay
time for a little bit of mailbag so
let's go through a couple of questions
here Charlie says bent happy Friday my
better half and I just had a positive a
tough talk last night about retirement
and savings recently we purchased a
beautiful new home here in Pennsylvania
so the next step logically would be kids
she says she wants to have more money
and savings prior to having kids in
order to be more financially secure well
I understand and respect this I don't
want to be an old fart raising a kid my
view is that you're never truly ready
I'm five six and 33 and she is 30 I
don't know what height has to do with a
dude but that's fine her parents are now
approaching their 70s minor in their 50s
what are your thoughts thanks
honestly it depends how many kids you
want to have I agree that there is no
such thing as the right time to have
kids
financially unless you happen to be
extremely well-off but the vast majority
of people over the vast swath of human
history have raised kids in houses that
were living on the borderline in terms
of financial security it turns out that
having kids is not really about saving
money and it really is never financially
secure to have kids I mean kids are
extraordinarily expensive the reason
that you have kids is because you're
making the world a better place and not
only I mean I assume that you and your
wife want to have kids I mean that's the
conversation but the point that I'm
making is that kids are not they should
they shouldn't be just a financial
function now that doesn't mean that you
should be responsible and have kids that
you truly can't afford meaning that you
have kids and then you expect everybody
else to pay for them but if it means
that you have to work harder you have to
struggle a little longer you can't
retire as fast
I'm not sure that that's a real answer
if everybody waited to have kids
they could afford them the world would
be over in lunge and so if you can
afford it meaning that you're not gonna
go bankrupt because you have kids then I
would urge you to do so because the
longer you wait the harder it is it also
depends how many kids you want to have
mean she's 30 around age 35 for women
just biologically speaking the chances
of a pregnancy going wrong go up pretty
dramatically in terms of having
pregnancy with with a birth defect for
example so you know I would suggest that
you get to work Lee says hello Jedi
Master Ben what do you think colleges
should do to improve their cost in
education my uncle says they spend a lot
of money preserving and renovating the
older buildings instead of tearing them
down and building new ones my personal
opinion of fixing education in classes
we should downsize and merge departments
for example merchants criminal justice
and Poli Sci well the real problem here
is that the cost structure is not being
driven by over staffing the cost
structure is being driven by over demand
so too many people are going to college
too many people are going to community
colleges who don't stay in too many
people are going to four-year colleges
who get degrees in useless nonsense the
fact is that we have as a country
decided to encourage everyone to go to
college and it's been a stupid stupid
move
a lot of people would be better off
going and starting a small business a
lot of people would be better off going
and working with their hands a lot of
people would be better off apprentice in
themselves in trade instead we encourage
everybody to go get a useless Women's
Studies degree at the local Community
College expecting $100,000 job coming
out and it's just idiocy in fact an
enormous amounts of student debt that's
piling up is piling up at the feet of
people who don't actually graduate from
college they go and they incur a bunch
of debt and then they don't end up with
the degree it's a lot better to
prospectively look and say what do I
actually wanted to agree in what is my
career path then just go to college and
assume that everything's going to be
fine
federal student loans by the way have
helped drive up education as well it is
not a coincidence that the price of
goods in the United States has been
dropping dramatically across the board
except in two cases health care and
education the reason that they've been
rising for both is because of increased
demand driven by increased government
subsidy subsidies and funding all these
places are seeing increased demand
because more people can afford to go to
college thanks to the government but
that also means that there's a shortage
of supply and too high a demand and the
prices go up Parker says hi Ben I'm
curious how the hamster fighting money
ever passed through Congress I think
that even if someone wanted it Rand Paul
would let the public know about it and
that would end
that of course the reference to a
project I discussed yesterday a funding
proposal for a particular grants to a
university study well this is the
problem with an administrative
government so it used to be that if
Congress wanted to fund a study about
hamster fighting then there'd actually
have to pass a bill saying I want to fun
to study about hamster fighting the no
one votes for it but instead because we
have administrative agencies what we do
now is we say the national endowment for
the sciences requires two billion
dollars in funding to give grants for
scientific research who's going to vote
against that nobody that sounds great I
mean scientific research and then we
pass the money along to the NES and then
the NES decides ok well we are going to
pass out that money as we see fit and
grant proposals that's how that money
ends up there now let's see Taylor says
you ever get the ad copy your sponsors
have you that your sponsors have you
read stuck in your head I find myself
thinking about investing in precious
metals Birch gold far more often that
I'm come through well the fact is that
our sponsors are all wonderful and I'm
proud to read their copy adam says hey
Ben you profess to be snobbish when it
comes to music and said that the issue
with rock as it came about in the 50s
and 60s was that skills replaced with
energy I'm a fan of many types of music
classical jazz rock metal hip hop and
others each has its place sometimes
passion or energy can be more important
than skill in order to convey emotion I
also think that things like superhero
movies have more of an energy than skill
and you seem to enjoy those for the most
part do you think that your classical
training is what has made you snobbish
in the area of music and not in others
thank you for all you do can't wait to
read the new book well number one go get
my new book it's great the right side of
history you can pre-order it now it's
coming out I think March 19th but as far
as skill and energy no I think that in
movies raw skill actually is a lot
better now than it was 30 years ago
which is why movies are a lot more
watchable and bad superhero movies are
performed with energy like Justice
League is a movie with energy and no
skill you know a lot a lot of movies
have energy and no skill I don't tend to
like those movies and there's a certain
amount of skill even to cheesy movies
that is required you actually have to
write a decent story the dialogue can't
be too dumb the art has to be beautiful
right that's pretty good description
right there of Aquaman but the fact is
that when it comes to the replacement of
skill with energy yes
energy conveys energy but it does not
necessarily uplift the mind uplift the
soul again I don't disagree that there's
there's a
I'm for energy but I think that the
dominance of energy over skill in
American society has been
extraordinarily bad for the arts and say
Daniel says if you had to pick a
philosophy other than theism to adhere
to which philosophy would you choose
would be objectivism utilitarianism etc
thanks shabbat shalom well you know I
picked my own philosophy and I don't
really like any of the others which is
why I picked it so it's hard to say that
I'd like I see aspects of truth in
objectivism in objectivism I sense the
you know the base guys you have
objectivism which is that we are all
driven by self-interest I think there's
a lot of truth to that I think that
objectivism goes overboard in the sense
that it suggests that any decision you
make is morally decent if it fulfils
that self that self-interest taking the
the kind of basis of capitalism and free
markets that your self-interest must be
traded for somebody else's self-interest
in order to make the world a better
place through markets and then extending
that so your personal life is a really
bad idea and you're gonna have to make a
lot of sacrifices and yes that requires
you to judge your own actions and the
actions of others not along a pendulum
of necessary self-interest but there's
some good ideas and objectivism about
economics utilitarianism I think
everybody makes certain utilitarian
judgments about things that they want
every single day so there are aspects of
other philosophies that I think are true
the reason that I am a theist is because
I think that virtually every other
philosophy has to base itself on certain
fundamental premises about your ability
to choose for example under objectivism
it's hard to not believe in free will
and be a libertarian Objectivist how do
you believe in free will without the
idea that you have the capacity to
overcome your own biological drives to
do something if you're a full
determinist then how do you make that
case how do you make the case that you
have the ability to comprehend the
universe such that you can make
decisions in the world
unless you believe that human beings
have access to universal truths not just
stuff that's effective but universal
truths if you believe that it's hard to
imagine how you do that in a world
without a God without a sort of logic to
the universe implanted by a creator that
we mirror in terms of our capacity to
create and choose all right so let's get
to a couple of things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so my daughter for the first
time I watched How to Train Your Dragon
which is a really underrated film one of
the great Oscar robberies in history
people like to talk about Oscar
robberies in terms of Best Picture so
listen this year I'm sure that it'll be
like Green Book or something
seen it yet maybe it's fine death of
Stalin wasn't even nominated clearly the
best picture of the year that I have
seen not even close I've said I think
it's one of the best pictures in the
last five years death of Stalin I think
that there are some other movies that
have not been now and a ballot of Buster
Scruggs I thought was really interesting
from Netflix that was not even nominated
but one of the great Oscar robberies of
all time happened in the year 2010 when
How to Train Your Dragon was nominated
for Best Score now the score is by a guy
named John Powell it is just a terrific
score it's a first-rate score it was
nominated against a couple of other
scores what one was the social network
Trent Reznor wrote the music to the
social network which is to say he wrote
four notes that repeat it's terrible
it's a terrible score and yet that one
and this score from How to Train Your
Dragon did not
I know people dismiss animated scores
this is a phenomenal score here's one
here's the flying theme from How to
Train Your Dragon by John Powell
[Music]
really terrific terrific score me it's
great it is such a great score it was up
against a cup I mean the social-network
winning that year it's not just that the
social-network winning in 2010 was a
travesty for it being chosen over How to
Train Your Dragon
it was also chosen over the scores to
inception and the King's Speech okay
that's it that's just ridiculous which
just goes to show you Oscar voters are
morons they're morons
I mean they cannot pick for that for the
life of them they cannot pick a decent
decent score it's just unbelievable it's
unbelievable okay so I get passionate
about this sort of stuff you talk about
skill or energy over skill that's a good
example the the first of all social
networking we have energy and the how to
train your dragon is so great every
night I actually this is our new bedtime
routine I put both my son and my
daughter on my back he climbs up first
cuz he's smaller and then she smooshes
him from back they climb up onto my back
and I put on this thing one that I just
run around the house then then they
throw them into bed and they go to sleep
which is great okay time for some things
that I hate so I know that we are now
rebelling against gender norms gender
norms we after a bell against them
because they are inconvenient apparently
it's now every year there's a thing
where people say that this is a thing
and it's not a thing okay just because
the media say something is a thing
doesn't mean it's a thing there's a
whole article over at people.com about
January because it's January but it's
January what is it it's a bunch of women
who decided that they didn't want to
shave their armpits and legs anymore
January encourages women to embrace
their body hair by growing it out
throughout the month this new craze was
started by Laura Jack like what
constitutes a craze like seven people
this new craze was started by Laura
Jackson a drama student at the
University of Exeter in the UK after she
noticed a difference in how she felt
when she grew out her body hair for a
rule right probably warmer right she
posted in a selfie and her Instagram
account I grew up my body here for a
performance as part of my drama degree
in May 2018 parents never let your kids
major in drama says there had been some
parts that were challenging for me and
others that really opened my eyes to the
taboo a body here on women after a few
weeks of getting used to it I started to
like my natural hair I also started to
like the lack of uncomfortable episodes
of Shaving so I felt liberated more
confident myself some people around me
didn't understand why I didn't shave and
didn't agree with it well not everybody
has to
like your personal behavioral choices
like this is one of my favorite things
is folks who decide to buck certain
societal norms and like but people don't
like it when I do that right and you
don't like the societal norm that's your
problem like people don't have to like
your your armpit hair congratulations
lady so I realized there's still so much
more for us to be able to do so except
to one another fully and truly like it
should be miss Crowe manatee let's cuz
but like this this new thing on the part
of leftists that they get to decide who
you are sexually attracted to is
astonishing to me they've done this with
regard to transgenderism as well and
that they will say with regard to
transgenderism for example that if you
are a man and you will not date a trans
woman this is because you are
transphobic so in other words if I don't
want to date a man who says he's a woman
that's because I fear trans women so now
you're gonna dictate who I'm sexually
attracted to god it okay and then this
is just another one of these okay well
listen you can not shave your armpit
hair that's fine but don't be surprised
when people judge you and think that
you're kind of a kook I don't know it's
tell you lady okay other things that I
hate so Jeff bestows is getting divorced
he's getting divorced because he was
basically having an affair with the
next-door neighbor which is amazing I
mean the dude is worth what a hundred
and forty four billion dollars he's
worth a hundred and forty four billion
dollars and he ended up having an affair
with the wife of his next-door neighbor
I mean you figure he has I mean he has
Amazon Prime he has access to anyone in
the world he couldn't go within like
with you know outside of ten-mile radius
I guess he was ordering from Amazon
fresh in any case Jeff Bezos was was
sending all sorts of kind of solicitous
texts to this lady his wife found out
about now she's divorcing him she made
the best you know people think he made
he was a great investor she made the
best investment of all time right she
spent twenty five years investing in
this and now it's gonna pay off to the
tune of seventy billion dollars
president Trump hates Jeff Bezos because
Jeff Bezos owns the Washington Post I
kind of like Jeff be so outside of his
personal life it sounds like he's kind
of a scumbag in his personal life I feel
that way by the way about everyone who
cheats on their wife I'm not a fan in
any case the the president the president
doesn't like Jeff Bezos if he really
wants to troll Jeff Bezos today all he
has to do is just tweet out a picture of
his prenups
because Jesus historic world-beating
genius didn't sign a prenup and now his
wife is going to walk away like how do
they make this split did she get to keep
Amazon Prime and he gets to just keep
regular Amazon hey how does that work
exactly I don't know but it's hilarious
okay so we will be back here next week
with all the latest presumably the
government shutdown will still be going
or maybe there will be a national
emergency or maybe the world will have
exploded or maybe an asteroid oh I don't
know but we'll be back here and we'll
recap all of it for you then i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam say whatz
Audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19